what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I'll be
talking about the latest major
developments in the black lower story
including an important reveal about
demons / devil magic that could have
massive consequences for the entire
story and for our boy hasta in
particular Meggie Cola the final dark
triad demon to be revealed continues to
surprise us with her insane power but
our heroes are not giving up and the
epic battle rages on so let's get into
it if you enjoy the black clover content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going please drop a like right now it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar or you just haven't
subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications I know it's annoying but
if you don't go through the trouble of
clicking that bell and then selecting
that option that says all you're still
gonna miss a lot of our videos even if
you're subscribed
it's just how YouTube works a huge thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
who make videos like this one possible
I'll talk more about patreon at the end
of the video but until then please be
advised that this video does contain
black clover manga spoilers we are of
course dealing with the latest
developments in the manga so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned at the very end of the previous
chapter the secret plan hatched by Noel
mimosa Laura chica and Sakura was
revealed they were waiting for Manica to
use as much of McGillis power as she
possibly can before using sac rez arcane
stage sealing magic to seal away
McGillis magic and its effects on this
world the girls believed that this would
stop Miki Kula in her tracks and also
cancel out the curse that was placed on
lorica chica by Miggy : however this
carefully calculated plan did not work
as intended the fact that it failed
becomes clear when Laura patchy cos
curse doesn't disappear and then we hear
that familiar laugh of a demon well you
know what it sounds like moving on
Meggie Kula laughs and says that even
though they are inferior beings humans
are interest
thing and they sometimes use magic that
surprises even a demon apparently given
a bit more time
McGee colas magic could really have been
sealed away but at this point in time
McGee Cola was able to break the seal
with her own overwhelming power by the
way I am referring to McGee glass female
just because of an acai and because it's
easier to refer to both of them as
female since they are acting together in
most cases but we have no idea if Meg
equalized female or if demons even have
males and females in the first place so
that's something to keep in mind
McGee Cola then actually emerges from
inside of Annika in order to communicate
directly with her opponents we see van
ACCA's face change and it appears as if
the entire right side of her body has
been completely taken over by McGee Cola
apparently McGee Cola possesses yet
another magic power the ability to
reduce the effect of its opponent's
magic on her and her host so even though
sucres arcane stage magic is extremely
strong
McGee Cola was able to resist it thanks
to her ability to reduce the effects of
her opponents magic by the way I started
referring to Nero as Sucre back when the
reveal happened and I just kind of
continued I know a lot of people still
call her Nero or narrow so let me know
what you guys prefer down in the
comments below anyway it is at this
point in the story that something very
interesting happens something that I
think is going to be very important for
the story going forward Vanegas Peaks to
McGee Cola directly and she tells McGee
: not to interfere in the fight because
Vanek ax is still having fun this might
seem like a pretty casual moment between
a demon and its host but this proves
that a demon or devil can take over its
hostess body or at least parts of its
hosts body against the hosts will even
though of Anika's possession by McGee
Kula as far as we know is a result of a
consensual contract between them
McGee Kula seems to be able to take over
even in moments when vantika doesn't
want her to
Vanek ik leer Lee wants to fight this
battle herself but McGee Cola is still
able to physically manifest within
Vanegas body and this changes Vanegas
physical appearance in
gives direct control over some parts of
Anika's body to McGee Kula this could
have very significant implications on
how the rest of the battles against the
dark triad will go and it could suggest
that even if our heroes are able to
defeat Dante and Zenon at some point in
the future that might not be the end of
their problems it is possible that the
demons will just take control of their
hosts bodies by force and so if our
heroes get even close to winning a
battle against any of the dark triad
members we could see the demon take over
and change the game completely
now that McGee Cola is manifesting
directly in the physical world the curse
that she had placed on Laura Pacheco and
Undine is in full swing and it appears
as if Undine is done for she can no
longer move and Laura Pacheco is in
tears because of what is happening Vanek
Estill wants to have a fun fight against
Laura Pacheco Radhika's whole purpose in
life seems to be to have fun and her
idea of having fun entails battles to
the death against strong opponents but
vantika believes that Laura Pacheco is
no longer going to be any fun to fight
our poor Beiber girl seems to have
succumbed to despair and she no longer
seems capable of putting up a fight at
all Vanakkam finds this turn of events
to be extremely boring and so she
decides that she might as well just kill
Laura Pacheco right now she also vows to
kill Noel and the others since they are
nothing without the direct help of Laura
Pacheco and her magic vantika says the
gap in power between her and the other
girls is just too big and so fighting
them would just be too boring it's not a
challenge and so it won't be any fun she
proclaims that the difference in their
power doesn't matter and she is
determined to take Wanaka on against all
odds
using her valkyrie dress form noel
declares that the vile actions of anakin
mega-cool cannot be tolerated and once
again Noel is able to use her lands to
pierce through Vanegas torso it appears
that the new Valkyrie dress mermaid form
allows Noel to be more maneuverable and
to dodge attacks more effectively but
the fact that she is now once again
using the original mockery dress seems
to suggest that she is now going all-in
on attack
I have to say that I have huge respect
for Noel and how she has evolved as a
character the amount of courage will
power and confidence that she is showing
right now in this battle against Monica
and McGee kala is incredible and it is
especially incredible when we remember
how Noel started out and how little true
confidence she had I mean sure she
pretended to be cocky and confident as
every good soon that it does but on the
inside she was actually deeply insecure
she is a completely different person now
and I absolutely loved her character
progression so far nevertheless we have
to remember that the last time though
I'll manage to pierce through Monica's
torso a few chapters ago vantika was
able to easily recover so I am not so
sure that this new attack will be very
effective this new attack definitely
proves Noelle's resilience and courage
but will this be the attack that ends
the entire fight and defeats vantika
I highly doubt it this chapter ends as
Noelle's attack Pierce's to its target
and we are left to wonder what will
happen next will Vanek actually be
defeated almost certainly not at least
not yet but will this attack be able to
make any sort of difference will it
perhaps succeed in pushing McGee Club
back inside of Anika thereby allowing
Undine to recover from the curse will
this attack force Manica to use even
more demon power in order to recover
which will allow Miggy Club to gain even
more control of her body or will this
attack do nothing at all let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
below but beyond just this specific
battle Miggy Kulas ability and
willingness to take control of part of
Anika's body against vana cos wishes
could have major implications for our
boy Austin in his recent battle against
Dante hasta tried his best but he was
soundly defeated this defeat absolutely
enraged Asta's demon and the demon
seemed determined to destroy Dante by
any means necessary I wonder if this is
a hint for what's to come is it possible
that the demon inside of Ash's grimoire
will grow tired of Austin's own
limitations and that he will one day
forcibly take control of Austin's body
against Asta's will this is something
that we have been speculating about for
a long time but these recent clues
Austin's demons rage in the face of
their loss to Dante and McGee colas
ability to take over parts of Anika's
body against her will do seem to support
the theory that one day Asta's demon
could take control of Austin's body
against his will if this happens I
expected to be in a moment of utter
desperation like the moment when asked a
thought that gauche had died and even
though this would clearly make us the
stronger
there is also a great deal of risk
involved with a scenario in which the
demon takes over Austin's body
completely
if hasta is no longer in control and the
demon is running the shots it is safe to
assume that the demon will not be nearly
as concerned about collateral damage and
protecting innocent people as hasta
would be the demon might force hasta to
do terrible things in pursuit of his
goals things that hasta could never take
back furthermore if Asta's demon
succeeds in taking full control of
Austin's body there is always the
possibility that the demon won't want to
relinquish control later on this could
lead to Asta's consciousness becoming
trapped inside his own body for a
significant period of time and meanwhile
his demon will emerge as the dominant
consciousness inside the body personally
I'm beginning to really like us as demon
and I hope that he is not the type of
demon who would take advantage of his
hosts in this way but at the end of the
day he is still a demon or devil so you
never know with that said it is possible
that Austin's demon cannot take over as
easily as McGee Kula because their
relationship to their respective hosts
is different austin's demon resides
within Auster's grimoire not within his
body itself and austin did not make any
sort of direct contract with the demon
in order to summon him into this world
austin's demon was already in this world
when he found hasta so perhaps hasta is
less obligated to his demon than the
members of the dark triad are to their
demons if we refer back to what Dorothy
Unsworth said about how demons are
summoned into this world it is fair to
assume that the dark triad members
willingly chose to summon the demons and
that they made deals with death this is
clearly different from hasta situation
so that could end up helping us to
maintain control of his own body but
we'll have to wait and see let me know
what you guys think is a stas demon
going to take over Austin's body at some
point in the future
or do you think that Auster's demon is
different and that the two of them will
continue to work together as a team
also how badass is our girl Noelle and
does she stand a chance against vantika
and Maggie Cola please share your
thoughts down in the comments below if
you enjoyed this video you want to see
more please slap a like it really does
help and if you're new to the channel or
you just haven't subscribed yet please
consider subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram ads anime uproar I
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible a very
special thank you to a friend a a
disciple of Lord Twigg o himself and I
can't forget all of our the one to your
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including in grata alone
Adam the world Steelers acquired respect
Pat a heffa Jonathan king deci d brandon
ivey less Papa Smurf the school bus King
riser Emperor otaku Ritchie Martinez and
Thomas Jones and of course another big
thank you to all of our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King zelgius Anatole Cassatt Sookie on
hell Cruz cricket XP Joe Stanton very
Gucci Alisha akhter Jessica Kayla fond
he no kami and water Bonnie Parks Zoda
are 12 rothwyn daiara Emperor cynical
Kraken full gas 77 and deadly Saint if
you enjoy our videos then you feel today
provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]